bartlett i'm very happy to have you all
here uh happy to be running this joint
symposium between the institute for
foundations of machine learning and the
uh computational complexity of
statistical inference program that we've
been running this semester
uh it's brought about 80 people uh
long-term visitors to to berkeley
um uh welcome to all the visitors from
ifml and a big thank you to ifml for uh
its support of of this symposium this
week very excited to have you here um
i should start by saying a big big thank
you to the organizers adam clovins jerry
lee and slittle shrum thanks to
those did a great job looks like an
exciting
exciting symposium um uh adam's going to
say a few words to introduce the
symposium in a moment um i have to tell
you about some of the logistics
uh so
please don't bring food and and coffee
into the auditorium uh water's fine
uh the
the rules about masking
uh have changed in alameda county but
not yet in the university so we all need
to wear masks inside
um
if you're heading out for lunch or other
times there are there are lockers on the
far side of the building on the ground
floor you're welcome to use those
uh
what's going to say um omid farr our
videographer here is going to be helping
speakers out with hooking up their
their computers
and of course a big thank you to kelani
pendleton our
events coordinator for all the local
arrangements thanks
all right adam go ahead
hi everyone i'm adam clivens and uh
notty was asking me what is ifml and as
peter just said we're the
national uh the nsf national ai
institute for the foundations of machine
learning
the nsf wanted to start a network of ai
institutes and so there are several now
we are the only ai institute whose theme
is foundations of machine learning
um simon's institute has always been
to me in my opinion like the place
to be if you want to do theory of
machine learning so we thought it made a
lot of sense to have a joint kind of
meetup session here at simon's institute
additionally i'm also one of the
organizers for this semester's program
thanks to peter bartlett thank you so
much for having us here hosting the
event providing refreshments and
logistics that's awesome it's also our
first kind of in-person event
for ifml our team members are primarily
from ut austin
uw
microsoft research and wichita state
university so you'll see
microsoft research right there so we'll
see you'll see plenty of people from
those institutes and
institutions and you know
hopefully you can
meet some people that you've only been
able to zoom with over the last two
years
our schedule today and throughout the
week we have two only two talks
scheduled for the morning for each one
of these days and our thinking was that
we wanted to leave all of you plenty of
time in the afternoon
to get good research done
and today in particular we have a
student poster session
um so that's a really important event
it'll be outside actually kelani told me
right over here there will be
refreshments and that's your opportunity
to you know introduce yourself and tell
everyone kind of what you're working on
and then we can spend sort of you know
find out who
uh the right connections for you to work
with for for the rest of the week so
um it should you know that's the main
event for today after after our two
talks that we'll be having so
um
yeah thanks again to the simons
institute and uh we're excited to have
uh ludwig here to kick us off
also if you want to check out any of our
events go to ifml.institute
it's our new website
um yeah thanks for putting it up in the
big so
right so um yeah this is a data-centric
view of robustness uh on robustness and
ludwig from uw is here to give the talk
thanks
cool excellent let's get started thank
you for the introduction and thanks a
lot for organizing this this is the
first time in a physical workshop in
quite a while
maybe true for many of you so i'm
excited to see people i can impress them
okay so this talk is going to be about
robustness at the beginning let's just
have a brief look back about over the
past few years of machine learning why
so many people are interested in
robustness now and then i'll tell you
why i think data is a really really
important component there
okay i mean this is not news to everyone
anyone there's been tons of interest
tons of excitement in the past 10 years
in machine learning if you sort of like
peel back maybe the outer layer of
excitement and hype sort of what are the
things that we've really made progress
on and then when you usually come back
to us there are lots of data sets lots
of benchmarks that we've gotten really
good at making the error numbers small
like the prime example of this paradigm
is imagenet right it was the alexnet
breakthrough moment
and after that people became really
really good at driving the error numbers
down by some measure take this with a
grain of salt to use superhuman
performance and this is not just
imagenet obviously this is sort of like
one example this entire paradigm like
basically there's a there are websites
like state of the art ml you can make
these plots for all sorts of data sets
like this is pascal voc ms coco
this is a segmentation data set
cityscapes i think this is squad natural
question answering
this is language modeling
this is machine translation and so forth
okay this is great this is really really
good progress the numbers keep getting
better on data sets of 10 years ago
people thought were really hard but ends
up like the natural question is as the
expectations are machine learning have
grown and you start deploying these
models how good are these new
classifiers really and by now we've come
to understand that actually just
performance on a single test set what
you usually do in this benchmark
paradigm doesn't tell you the full story
i think a very nice case study here is
self-driving cars around 2015 everyone
was excited by 2020 they would be
self-driving cars
elon musk is particularly nice to pick
on here a little bit
because his predictions have just always
been very crisp so once then it's early
2018
elon musk predicted that within half a
year there would be an autonomous tesla
goes to coast drive
then 2018 passed
um 2019 mid 2019 now elon treats parking
lots a remarkably hard problem so
instead of coast to coast we now do
parking lots and he was going to do an
engineering review later today
for enhanced summon the idea being that
you can call your tesla to come to you
from the other end of the parking lot
and then they released this
a few months later and then typically
what happens of all of these tesla
releases you have people post videos
like this and youtube fairly short
shortly after the release and here the
car would almost have hit another car if
the person hasn't stopped it so this is
clearly still a very hard problem and to
be fair to test that this is a hard
problem for everyone lots of smart
people are working on this it just turns
out making machine learning reliable in
the real world is really tricky and
again this is not just self-driving cars
this is a nice sort of like benchmark
survey paper and extra image
classification
and they reach the same conclusions
there even in the absence of recognized
confounders so they don't really know
what's going on they caution that
current accuracy numbers are brittle and
susceptible to even natural variations
in the data distribution
and this is clearly a problem we need to
sort of like tackle and ideally solve it
if we want to deploy machine learning
broadly right a lot of the applications
you would like to apply machine learning
in are safety critical applications like
transportations and healthcare we just
talked about that the past year i spent
it to you the research because i wanted
to learn more about robotics online
content moderation and so on so in all
of these cases you really do want
machine learning to be reliable
okay good
so how what can we do to make the models
more reliable and how reliable are the
models at the moment in various ways so
this is going to be the
topic of this talk this is going to be
in two parts
and i'll always emphasize the key role
of data the regular data sets play in
the first part of the talk we'll do a
broad overview over the robustness
landscape with a focus on image
classification
because this is where a lot of this work
has happened and here we'll use data
sets in order to evaluate models in
interesting ways
and a key outcome of the first part will
be that train data sets also on the
training side play a very important role
in making the models more robust and in
the second part of the talk we'll look
at the probably most impressive example
of that so far open the ice club model
and see how we can use better training
data to make the models more robust
and overall what i think comes out as a
conjunction this the work on the
training data side is for some of these
distribution shifts really the only way
forward like sometimes when we think
about robustness of the approaches okay
if we come up with a better training
algorithm and extract more signal out of
our training set we can make the model
more robust
after working on this for a while
i think for some of the distribution
shifts this may just be impossible and
the only way forward is really studying
training sets and coming up with better
training sets
okay cool so let's get started and
throughout the talk if there any
questions feel free to interrupt me
okay so the first part of this talk as i
said this overview of the robustness
landscape this is based on this paper
here that i wrote back when i was a
postdoc here at berkeley so the first
author who had to ori he was actually at
the time in undergrad super fantastic
archived
and what we wanted to do in this paper
is sort of like get an overview of all
the different ways people were measuring
robustness at the time and still an
image classification
i think some of these probably many of
you have seen before look like the most
common way people have studied
robustness and image classification over
the past few years is adversarial
examples you take an image that a
classifier easily classifies correctly
you add a little bit of carefully tuned
noise and then the
classifier says something completely
nonsensical
another type of robustness that people
study is sort of like consistency of
predictions and across time and videos
like you have this bunny here eating a
toast and if you look at the frames
before and after in a video sometimes
the classifier gets it perfectly right
and sometimes again it says something
purely nonsensical now there is no
adversary at play
and yeah this is clearly an issue if you
want reliable predictions over video
this is another type of robustness that
people have studied a lot you take a
test set that you have like imagenet and
you apply various corruptions like say
add gaussian noise add a synthetic grain
pattern add a synthetic fog pattern and
so on and typically again accuracies go
down
this one we'll talk about in more detail
i call this dataset shift here when
people just come up with new test sets
and then feed them into the classifiers
um to understand how this model does on
a completely new test set
there are many more things like
geometric transformations you take these
images you sort of like rotate them
translate them maybe you even render
them in different ways if you have a 3d
setup and a renderer and overall there's
just lots of work in this area nicholas
scalini i think he even read all the
abstracts until 2019 and kept track of
the papers and there was a lot of
activity good and so for now i want to
well for this paper we wanted to see
okay
like are these different robustness
notions if a model does better in one of
these robustness notions does this also
help other robustness notions and so on
and we did all of this in the context of
imagenet so this
is i think a good starting point here
because we have a lot of common test
beds for imagenet models a lot of these
distribution shifts were studied first
in the imagenet context and often
findings that you have on imagenet
also transfer to other datasets we look
at other data sets a bit later but for
now the focus is on imagenet
everyone by now knows what imagenet is
it's a large image classification data
set one million training images a
thousand classes and the task you have
to do is just take a picture like the
stock and classify it as a golden
retriever
okay so what is the core sort of like
object of study in this paper
it's this matrix okay what is this
matrix basically this is our big
evaluation breaks what we have here on
the
y-axis are 200 different models
basically we tried to evaluate
everything that we could find on github
if someone had put out a pre-trained
imagement model we plugged it into our
testbed
and then on the x-axis we have 200
different distribution shifts same idea
if someone had proposed a way to
evaluate imagenet model
we plugged it into our testbed and this
gave us a new column
okay so overall each cell in this matrix
corresponds to evaluating one model
on one test set and then if you do this
you get about a billion image
evaluations um nikolas google was
helpful in this sort of thing giving us
some compute to do this
and yeah so just to give you a little
bit more detail what's in this test bed
let's first look at the y-axis what kind
of models do we have so at a high level
let's divide this into three categories
of models
the first one is what we call standard
models these are models that were just
built to do balan image net sort of like
starting from alex net over bgg resnet
and so on this entire slew of models
where the sole focus of the
corresponding paper was to get a higher
emergency number
and the second class of models is what
we call robust models these are all
sorts of models that people developed
with the focus on making the model
robust to something what they made the
model more robust to this various
depending on what the authors were
targeting but this is for example
adversarial training or randomized
smoothing special data augmentation
special filtering layers and so on
and then the third category
of
models that we have in a test builder
model strain on more data
we'll talk about the exact details of
this when they become relevant
but this is sort of like the rough
structure on the y-axis
and then on the x-axis we have as i said
a ton of different distribution shifts
various test sets that people proposed
we'll talk about those in more detail
l infinity attacks of various strengths
l2 attacks of various strengths various
image corruptions and so forth
okay so there's a lot of stuff in this
test spread the nicest once you once you
start building this you get sort of like
this quadratic increase and how many
interesting things you can find
um
for today the focus is on one
distinction that i think is quite
important with the on the x-axis of the
distribution shifts and this is what we
sort of at a high level call this
distinction between synthetic
distribution shifts and natural
distribution shifts what do i mean by
this
so with synthetic distribution shifts we
mean distribution shifts that someone
really just created in a computer you
take the say image in a test set and
then you apply some perturbation to each
image let's say you add an adversarial
perturbation or you add gaussian noise
and so on and this is a good starting
point because this makes it easy to come
up with many different distribution
shifts but that catches the resulting
test set is not a real image like no one
ever recorded that image
and so in contrast to that what we call
a natural distribution shift
is a test set that someone really
collected in the real world like every
image there is an unperturbed example
that someone just took up as a picture
with their camera
and we'll see how well the models do on
that
and i think this distinction is
important
because a lot of the robustness work
so far has focused on this world here as
i said this is a natural starting point
so for control setup but in the end we
want to make sure that the models are
actually more robust than real data i
think this is why complementing
evaluations of natural distribution
shifts is important
cool any questions so far in the setup
some of the
datasets were actually attacks so
were these
did you evaluate so is it one more
there's static there is nothing
for the distribution shifts where we say
lp adversarial example l infinity with a
certain strength we actually run pgd for
each one
good question thanks
okay cool so before we look at the
results for some of these distribution
shifts we need to agree on one more
thing and this is how we are going to
quantify robustness
and once you if you build such a large
testbed of models the tricky part is
that in distribution accuracy becomes
our confounder like to illustrate this
with a simple example let's say we have
two models model a and model b
model a gets eighty percent accuracy
model b gets ninety percent in
distribution
and then we look at the out of
distribution test set model a get 75
percent model b77 so which of these two
models is the more robust one if you
just pragmatically approach this well i
want to deploy the best model you should
clearly go with model b because model b
still has higher accuracy out of
distribution
but if we are more interested in um
consistency across distribution shifts
and how well these models do
then the model a is actually more
interesting because model a sees only a
five percentage point accuracy drop
and model b sees a 13 percentage points
accuracy drop
and so this is why we look primarily at
accuracy drops across distribution
shifts
and the nice thing is that for all of
the distribution shifts we study this is
also a very
regular way of
looking at robustness why is that what
do you mean by this so now let's start
looking at some concrete
data in our test set so x these are sort
of these scatter plots are going to be a
key element in this talk so let's go
through the step by step x-axis is
imagenet type one accuracy so in
distribution
y-axis is imagenet v2 or some other
out-of-distribution test set
and every point in this plot is one
model that we've evaluated okay
and these are the blue points are always
the standard imaging models so these are
models just trained to do well on image
now
and the interesting thing here is for
some reason we don't know exactly why
all of these models follow a very clean
linear trend okay
as i said we don't exactly know why this
happens but it happens basically it
happens for all models that we plugged
in
and this basically now gives you a
baseline for evaluating robustness if
that newborn comes in we can just look
at okay what is this in distribution
accuracy then we look at our linear
trend we can read off what the model
should be getting out of distribution if
it behaves like a standard model and
then what we would like for a model to
achieve is that it gets what we call
effective robustness when we say a model
is truly more robust here if it's above
the red line by some amount
the more you are above the red line the
better invite this a reasonable goal so
ideally you would be on y equals x the
dashed line right so the same
performance on the two test sets
and this is a reasonable goal because
humans can do it right in this entire
robustness business sort of like the
disappointment is always that the models
aren't quite as reliable as the human
virtual system
and
um for this image and intermission to be
two distribution shifts we run an
experiment with trained expert labelers
and they actually do land here so if we
want to be as robust as humans you would
like large effective robustness so that
we also land over there
okay and then the big question is do any
of the current robustness interventions
or more data models have effective
robustness on these distribution shifts
okay so
let's look at some
let's look at some data we look at four
natural distribution shifts in our
testbed dimensional v2 object net
imagenet sketch and imagenet r
to be clear there's a lot more people
have done in the community on evaluating
models and out of distribution data like
two examples here that are very nice
the wireless collection of benchmarks
and breeds
the problem with those is that you need
to train models specifically for these
data sets the nice thing with the
imagenet based test that is you can just
plug in everything that people have
tried to train on imagenet and you can
evaluate it in an earthquake
okay cool so the first
test that we are going to look at is
imagenet v2 this is from a paper that i
also did during my postdoc here here the
idea was let's try to recreate the
imaginary data segregation process as
closely as possible as we could at the
time so imagenet was built from flicker
as an image source cleaned with
mechanical twerk then you get some
accuracy at the time when we did this
top one was 83 for the best model
and then we repeated this
and we only got
72 so this is
not exactly iid so small differences do
creep and when you do this especially on
the amtrak side the point is just that
this 11 percentage point accuracy drop
in the context of emissions is actually
quite large this corresponds to about
five years of progress on the data set
and ideally a robust model wouldn't have
this law because humans don't have it
yes
you're just taking
the same images
and you're just having them clean
in two different it's not exactly the
same interest thanks for clarifying
basically we got new images out of
liquor so the data source for the
original image and i tested slicker
and then they used emter to
sort of filter the flicker images
because it's quite noisy so we did the
same we got new images out of flickr
similar time frame and so on you have a
lot of control of the flicker api
and then we also did a very similar mtar
process to filtered images
so it's not exactly the same images but
the same source and we also use the same
keywords and the flicker api and so on
to make it as similar as a distribution
as possible
all right so what is this
it is it is the same
it is not i mean you can match all these
things
and so there's a big question like what
is actually different right because if
it was exactly the same distribution you
wouldn't see the 11 there and i think
this is a great question um i think the
current evidence points towards
small differences in the mtar setup
like there are variables like how do you
exactly set up your task how much do you
pay the workers what i mean the worker
population also changes over 10 years
like he did this in 2018
they built image that in 2008 so the
type of people who did
back then is different
motivations change and so on i think
this actually is the key
okay to be very precise there
the imagenet the test set was built
until 2012.
we took images from mid-2012 when
imagenet was fixed the machine tester
was fixed to mid 2013. so there is a
one-year temporal distribution shift why
did we do this because we didn't want to
overlap with the imagenet
period because then the confounder would
have been what if imagenet took out all
the easy images and only the hard images
are left in the flicker data source so
we said okay let's use a different time
period because then we don't have any
overlap with image nut and one year
temporal shift shouldn't be a big
difference here because imagenet was
built over multiple years anyway
but this was a player i think yeah i'm
happy to check more about this later i
think it's the amtrak test
but would also be interesting to look at
the time variation in more detail
yes question yeah so if i'm right this
is uh like you trained on the first set
and then you test
did you try the other way around um we
did this in the context of our user
lucifer 10 test set not in the context
of the imagenet test set because
building these data sets takes a lot of
time and we only build a test set like
the tester is like 10 000 the training
set is 100 times larger size of million
would love to do it um if you give me
any money to do it i do it
great point
okay so let's look at our results plot
here okay this is now all 200 models on
the scatter plot imagenet versus imagine
that v2
and now when you look at this you're
going to think that maybe like huh this
really looks a bit like the plot i've
just seen before there's not that much
action going on in the sense that all
models
are still very close to the red line and
yes this is the correct observation so
basically none of the robustness
interventions that we currently have
don't really do anything for the
imagenet v2 distribution shift
the only models that stand out a little
bit
are the green points so these are
here and these as we said are models
trained on more data
a bit more specifically
this point here is trained on imagenet
21k so the larger full original training
set 10 times more images
and these are two or these are a range
of models trained by google and facebook
so instagram one billion this is trained
by facebook on one name suggests one
billion images
and this one here is trained by google
and 300 million images
so this is now a thousand times more
training data than imagenet and the gain
you get here's one to two percentage
points the job is about 10. so this is
far from closing the gap
in your images right
there oh yeah these instagram these are
new images
no this is the same this is the same
roughly the same
dataset creation process so when it's
funny when they did the imagenet
competition in 2012
they actually used a subset of the data
they had already collected
so this is really roughly the same
creation process and time period jft i
don't know this is google proprietary
cool okay so maybe there's something
special about imagenet v2 and i don't
know we don't know to what extent this
is a representative distribution shift
so the good news is over the past few
years many more teams but test sets like
emission at v2
one nice one for instance is object net
this is from a team around josh
tenenbaum
at mit
and um here the idea was
let's actually spec directly challenge
the model so imagine that b2 was more
like let's be as friendly to the models
as possible here now they were like okay
we want to see how robustly models
generalized and what did this as follows
is a very nice idea they just told crowd
workers
um hey take an object in your home like
a chair she has an object an imagenet
and put it in an unusual orientation in
an unusual place the idea being that
often dining chairs are more in the
kitchen and they wanted to break their
correlation so they told people rotate a
chair by 90 degrees and put it in the
bathroom and so on so it's always still
the right object the idea is as a human
you can tell what it is
but you remove a lot of the correlations
that are present in imagenet
okay great so let's plug this into our
test map let's run the 200 models on
this and see what we get so this is the
plot we get and so like as a first
approximation is again looks like the
plot we've just seen with the one big
difference that now the drop is much
larger so for image net v2 the drop was
about 10 percentage points 10 to 12 and
now here it's more like 30 or 40.
and then again none of the models have a
lot of effective robustness everything
is pretty close to this red line the
only points that stand out a little bit
again are the green points here train on
more data
okay and then
let's look at two more image net sketch
and imagenet r
um so an imagenet sketch the idea was
well let's just see how the imagenet
classifiers do on sketches
collected i think from google image
search sketches corresponding to a
subset of the
imagenet classes and then imagenet r
which is from broccoli here this is sort
of like a supercharged version of
imagenet sketch where they have various
types of renditions not only sketches
but also models a couple of points here
that are above the line these are
various state augmentation methods so
they help here
and the yellow points they are now
a separate color this is adversarial
training so they do offer
quite a bit of effective robustness here
they're quite a bit of the red line the
thing to keep in mind is
this model here if you don't do
adversarial training is roughly over
here so you're not actually gaining out
of distribution you're basically making
the model worse in distribution but you
maintain it's out of distribution
accuracy
and then you can look at image.r right
we said these two are roughly or similar
in terms of what they test actually i
think imagenet sketch is a subset of
imagenet r and similar story here the
more data models are doing the best
a couple of the data augmentation
methods also help and then there are the
adversarial robust models see that for
some reason i don't know why get a good
amount of effective robustness but it's
not something you would actually do
okay good so
this is what's happening on the natural
distribution shifts just for
completeness
let's also look at the synthetic
distribution shifts in our test bed
because we have that data
and we look at two plots one for image
net c and one for
adversarial robustness so emission let's
see all these corruptions here in the
picture
and um these image corruptions this is
now where data augmentation really
shines
so again we look at the scatter plot
the brown points here all various forms
of data augmentation they have the
largest effect of robustness the largest
lift above the line and interestingly
the models train on a lot more data the
green points that really stood out on
the natural distribution shifts they
don't have any
properties anymore they just behave like
a normal invention trade model
and then one last plot this is
the
l infinity and l2 attacks and this is
now where adversarial training shines
because this is what it's trained to do
so like we have these models here
randomized smoothing and resilient
training which is doing really well and
then the other models are doing
substantially worse
okay so like what is the
take away from all of this
so
on these natural distribution shifts we
have
four or five examples of them now um
most of the robustness dimensions don't
really work that but sometimes data
augmentation helps but the best thing by
far is always just training on larger
more diverse data sets
but even for these models strengthen a
thousand times more data
there's still a lot of room for
improvement right we said the emission
v2 accuracy drop is 10 percentage points
training on a thousand times more data
only gives you two percentage point
improvement
if you want to look at more of this data
we have sort of like a plotting web ui
you can go to robustness.imagenetv2.org
and generate all 10 000 plots you can do
with the testbed
um yeah for now
this is overall i think a little bit so
like for me at least when i saw this was
a little bit sobering and not really
great news but this is also happening in
other places where people do large scale
robustness evaluations
there's a very nice paper from people at
facebook in search of lost domain
generalization dimensionalization is a
closely related problem to the zero
short robustness that we look at in this
talk and they basically find the same
thing they say in the abstract we
conduct intensive extensive experiments
using domain bet this is the new
benchmark and find that when carefully
implemented empirical risk minimization
shows state-of-the-art performance
across all data sets so basically they
had a couple dozen
methods implemented for
dimensionalization and they found it a
well-run standard empirical risk
manifestation it doesn't really take
robustness into account did as well or
better than all of the
dimensionalization methods
okay cool well all of this is very
focused uh question
you say a world about your predictions
so when you predict you take the test
image do you buy the documentation and
make a vote but
just
oh you mean like what about test time
augmentation
you mean like what about test time
augmentation as a method
that's a good question and probably we
tried this at some point i don't
remember if it's one of the 200 models
but i don't and i don't think test time
augmentation helps
more than standard
training augmentation
thanks
um yeah what about other fields
of computer version so this was at the
moment very centered on image
classification
um and basically a high level similar
phenomena show up in different places
there's a paper earlier this year where
they do a similar study in mri
reconstruction they plot it a bit
differently but you also see this like
linear trend and all the models
basically you see across it dropped by
roughly the same amount
because i was looking at robotics over
the past year we did something with pose
estimation so we want to estimate the 60
pose of an object similar story there
this is from people at google led by
becker
and they
looked at distribution shifts and object
detection similar story there so you get
these nice linear trends and models tend
to follow the same linear trend i think
if anyone has any ideas for when and why
this is happening i would be very
curious we actually wrote an entire
paper on this don't have time to go into
all the details here but basically we
look at just a lot of different
distribution shifts and you often see
this nice behavior that basically all
the models do the same thing the only
thing that matters for out of
distribution accuracy is your
distribution accuracy
um so this one here okay this one here
these are trained on two different um
training sets so this is always a
property of the training distribution
like all of these models that follow the
same linear trend they are trained on
the same training distribution
and this is robust under all sorts of
things you can do you can early stop you
can change your hyper parameters i think
this is a particularly nice one
you can also just train on a subset of
your data and you go exactly along this
red line so if i train on only two
percent of the cipher 10 data in this
example i'm exactly
moving along the red line
and this is going to be useful later
this is going to be actually really
useful because this allows you to make
statements about much larger training
sets from training on very small
training sets right if this is a very
reliable scaling law then we should be
able to run all of our experiments on
like one percent of the data and in the
end be able to say what's going to
happen on all of the data and we'll do
this in about five minutes
cool and also just for completeness not
all distribution should save this
property i don't know when this happens
as i said we'll be super happy to chat
about when and why this happens this is
one example from the wireless test bed
this is tissue classification and that
scatter plot is just a total mess
some of the synthetic distribution
shifts are also pretty messy this is
adding gaussian noise it's a bit ironic
the one distribution shift that can
describe mathematically you just add
gaussian noise to each pixel gives you
the messiest scatter plot
but okay this is what's going on there
oh
since we again so far everything has
been focused on computer vision we did
similar experiments in nlp building new
test sets for question answering data
sets and again similar trends throughout
there as well
yes
[Music]
this is definitely a good experiment to
do
we didn't do that because
we don't have time stamps for all of the
imagenet training images
in order to do that you would need to
know for the imagenet training set when
was the picture taken and that
information is not available
for question answering you can do
different time periods here what we did
was different source corpora like
instead of only wikipedia we also new
york times threaded on amazon
yeah you can definitely do this it's a
good amount of work like like one of
these
papers usually is like about a year of
right building these tests and so on but
yeah that would be a great question
okay cool yes sorry guys
oh
um
this is john carl and me basically the
authors of the paper we also tested
ourselves
so what is the method i mean the method
is
very different oh yeah it's humans it's
myself
um basically we wanted to make sure that
ideally like humans are on y equals x
and these plots here we are a little bit
below so the data quality for od tested
is not exactly where you would want it
to be ideally the humans are on the
dashed line
but basically this is just
indicating that yes you can do better on
ood than the models currently do
i mean i'm trained for 30 years now but
yeah
uh we did not train on the old testament
we'd be trained on i mean
i hesitate to call it training because i
was heavily pre-trained but um we did a
bit of training on the squad training
set just do we learn how the task works
and some of the influences and then we
tested ourselves on these tests
the same for the imagenet
we have evaluation five minutes we need
to go a little bit faster but these are
all great questions any more questions
okay so so far we have seen that these
natural distribution shifts had to be a
pretty hard problem and none of the
methods so far made progress except
there's one
big outlier that appeared earlier this
year
and this is open the eyes clip model
and this was super surprising partially
because of the following plot here right
i just showed you this and we said that
even training on a thousand times more
data gives you only small robustness
gains on this test set right so like do
a silly extrapolation maybe
two percentage points four thousand
times more data than you need to like
ten to the ten times more data or
something or to close this gap this is
clearly not realistic
but the interesting thing is that you
can actually do much better so this is
the clip paper from earlier this year
the openi train models jointly on
language and versions of basically
images with associated text to
supervision
and they just did extremely well on
these ood test sets so what they did on
this paper is very nice they followed
exactly our recipe for evaluating
robustness
so you take your clip model then you
just trained you compare it to an
imagination model as the same accuracy
so these differences are effective
robustness what they show you here
and these numbers are just really large
like six percentage points on image and
v2 this is half of the drop and then
plus 50 percent on image and r plus 40
on object net plus 35 and
imagenet sketch and 74 we have a look
there's another od test set on imagenet
like if you work in machine learning you
know that it's very rare to get plus 50
gains on these like competitive test
sets just because they can't happen too
often right if you did this twice then
the dataset would be solved
um this was my life reaction in a chat
and select the friends when this came
out and yeah i just i still find this
like super super interesting and then
when you scatter plot these models that
they have the clip models they actually
this is straight out of their paper
again
you basically see that they are really
qualitatively very different like the
orange lines of like baseline these are
the club models they propose evaluated
in a consistent way and you get this
nice linear trend again i don't know why
and it's just much much better than the
imagenet models the blue line or all of
the more data models that people have
proposed before the green points
and
yeah good i mean like what do you do
with this um well like why is it so good
and
the interesting thing is when you look
at sort of like figure one in the paper
and how this model is trained nothing
about this method is explicitly focusing
on robustness like this is sort of like
the architecture
you show this to a first year grad
student and they will know what's going
on oh okay text encoder transformer
contrast the flaws image encoder
confident or transformer done so the
method is very very simple i think this
is part of beauty here and i think this
strongly points towards training data
really being the key so why this model
is so good yes
oh fine tunic great question um
we'll get to that um i mean okay you can
fine-tune just by
using a last layer that you get from
your text encoder and then doing either
last layer or end-to-end fine tuning
for yeah great question so when you
fine-tune here this is actually what
our contribution is here probably only
from minnesota anyway if you they
basically took their monops and then
they fine-tuned them on emotion
and then you get their deadline
and you were asking like
the orange line is just zero shot
evaluation of these models yes this is
the zero shot evaluation of these models
this is what you get after fine-tuning
your dimensions
okay and did you know what they
train they know where their image is
factored into the
idea
like this image and the subset of your
training set i don't think so
i have never asked them this
specifically i know some things about
their tests that their training is that
but overall the training set is private
okay and so here since we talked about
fine tuning this somewhat unfortunate
thing is if you fine-tune these models
of image night you do get quite a bit
better in distribution on imagenet but
you actually even lose some of the
robustness what would be ideal is if you
just moved further along the orange line
but actually what happens is that you
will lose some of the out of
distribution performance
so the question we asked ourselves
was can you do better can you improve
both in distribution and out of
distribution accuracy when you fine tune
and the answer is yes and i'm
in the interest of time not going to
tell you anything about this because
mitchell and gabriel are here
and they have a post i think in the
poster session this afternoon and tell
you more can tell you more about the
details the point is with a very simple
method you can actually substantially
improve
over the results from open ai so this is
what they told us to do for end to end
fine tuning and then our improved fine
tuning gets nine percentage points
better out of distribution so this is a
pretty large gain on top of the already
large gains they have
and
maybe just one point here that i want to
highlight because i think this is very
very nice and this is sort of not
actually how the method works but how we
got there so what this plot shows you is
the robustness gain
of our fine tuning method as a function
of compute amount you put in
and as i told you these linear trends in
these plots are really reliable scaling
laws so what we actually did was a lot
of experimentation the small to medium
regime compute wise because we're at uw
we don't have as much computers open ai
actually far less compute but the cool
thing is
if you find a model of effective
robustness in this low compute regime
there's a really
good hope that this will transfer over
to the much more expensive high compute
regime and this is exactly how we did
this michelin gabriel a super creative
experimentalist they found a method that
worked in the slow accuracy regime and
then we just sent this to our
collaborator chengwook at openai and
asked them hey can you run this on your
largest model with all the compute you
have basically and this worked on the
first try so this is nice because this
really allows you to do model design on
a small scale and then just scale things
up and you know that things should work
out
okay cool yeah this is more on this we
don't have time for that now cool so
this is basically everything i want to
tell you and we're also at 40 minutes so
that's good
um let's go quickly to this conjecture
because this is something if some anyone
has insights on this i would be super
happy as i mentioned
basically when we make these scatter
plots everything falls on these linear
trends like you can do random forests
here random features convonnets linear
regression gaussian kernel it doesn't
matter it also goes exactly to 10 10 so
even a random classifier is on this line
that all the models fall on and i don't
know why this is and i wonder if this is
some sort of like fundamental limitation
of training only on the surface training
set that you inherently can't do better
than this red line on an out of
distribution test set same thing shows
up on imagenet we've seen this
the tricky part is it's actually really
trivial to get away from this red line
in a pretty nonsensical way you can just
take any point here on this line and you
interpolate it with a random classifier
this is a little technical now you've
maybe noticed that the plots look a bit
weird in terms of scaling these are
extreme logic domain the lines are only
lines and logic domain and then
interpolating with a random classifier
sort of like traces out something above
the red line the thing is yes this is
above the line but it's also a pretty
stupid thing to do because interpolating
of a random classifier only makes your
model worse
so yeah as i said if anyone has thoughts
on this please let me know
and for now let's conclude so first part
of the talk we did this high level
overview of robustness
and it's pretty clear from that that
some robust notions are basically
orthogonal like adversarial robustness
and these natural distribution shifts
kind of have nothing to do with each
other improving on one doesn't help you
with the other or vice versa on the
other hand there are some consistent
trends among some of the distribution
shifts like imagenet v2 object net
imagenet r emissions catch they all
behave roughly the same which i think is
good news i think overall you just need
to understand a lot more about how these
different robustness notions interact
and then sort of on the second part of
the talk we've seen that
training data allows you to make tons of
progress on these distribution shifts
and i think this raises a question how
do we construct sort of universal
training sets that have coverage over a
wide variety of different test sets
um
yeah and i'm happy to take more
questions now as i mentioned if you like
scatter plots now you can plot a lot of
them on robustness.image.v2.org
and i'm thanks for listening and i'm
happy to take questions
any questions
so
some of the earlier plots
in some of the earlier plots uh you were
able to do better with that augmentation
but also some of the
points much below the line were also
data augmentation yes or more using more
training data um do you know if there's
like a systemic difference between the
date the additional training data that
you found
yeah so this is the thing with some of
these more data models you basically
take the checkpoints that large
companies like google or facebook
release and we don't know exactly what's
going on one indeed funny phenomenon is
that some of these more data points are
below the line
i think they're all from the same team
at google i don't know exactly what they
do but i think they fine tune their
models in a funny way i think they may
fine-tune them too much on imagenet and
then maybe it does worse on other
testers i don't know it's a good
question we've definitely noticed this
that
uh yeah like also
you as i said you can go to this left
side and mouse over these points to see
exactly what they are um it's a good
question like one funny thing is
there's one blue point here that stands
out a lot sorry on object net if you go
back to
to go back to object net you're like
okay all of the blue points are roughly
on the line and then there's one sort of
like maybe even five percentage points
above what is going on with this guy
here and it turns out this is a model we
imported from a google train testbed and
this one here was trained with rotation
as state augmentation then if you go
back to how object net was built yes
it's about rotations
so all of the like rotation is not a
standard image and a date augmentation
normally just do translations
in flips
seems like the rotation does help you
like in general sort of like to be
fair-to-date augmentation if you know
what your distribution shift is you
should totally just state augmented this
is a very good pragmatic way of going
about it what i'm interested in here
research wise are the distributions
where i don't know how to date augment
thank you
it's just a quick clarification question
so what's the whisker represent in all
your plots oh this is these are just uh
95 percent confidence intervals uh for
for the tested size like the test sets
have finite size we are estimating a
population accuracy from a finite size
test set so there is some uncertainty
from that so these are just by normal
proportion confidence intervals
i see thanks
thanks for clarifying
okay let's thank ludwig again
[Applause]
next talk is naughty at 11.